avant l'entrevue jean marc dalpé jeu
m'avait dit je pourrais vous donner une
leçon dramaturgie mais ça va vous coûter
de l'argent
les caméras rôle je veux savoir quelle
est votre secret pour écrire autant de
pièces en 40 ans de carrière est aussi
percutant je la recette veille après je
pense qu'il ya certaines maps hop une
recette
il ya un élément important c'est le
temps puis ça c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
assez aux artistes créateurs de la
pression du marché de l'art du le manque
de subventions qui minent sait que sa
gauche le temps qu'on active pour créer
et qu'on est obligé de faire des arrêts
le plus d'affaires que tu fais mais
peut-être à faire des plus d'affamés la
qualité vont nécessairement baisse
on a besoin de temps voilà jean marc
dalpé où vous habite à montréal depuis
30 ans mais vous n'êtes ni à ottawa
oui vous considérait toujours comme
franco ontarien j'ai bien remarqué votre
pratique oui absolument
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous
cette identité de franco ontarien qu'on
va écouter le ce que je raconte tout le
temps de l'identité il faut le monde et
c'est celle que j que je choisis que
j'ai choisi c'est une identité qui est
plus poétique que politique
dans ce sens-là montréal l'époque la
métropole du québec montréal est la
métropole de l'amérique francophone donc
sans quelque part oui je suis citoyen
canadien citoyens québécois mais je
demeure franck ontarien is it c'est chez
nous et tout votre toute nouvelle pièce
la queen's que juste derrière nous
justement
oui parle de famille d'un lien familial
d'identité c'est vraiment un thème
récurrent à 28 est ce qu'on peut dire
traumatisé un peu par la question
identitaire dans toute votre oeuvre
créer un choc certains mais je pense que
oui c'est sûr qu'il ya manille
dans dans ma vie parce que je suis de
jeu je porte en moi ce ce conflit
historique qui politique anglo franco à
qui guéant à l'intérieur de ma famille
mais à l'intérieur de moi fait que ça
toujours ça souvent été des questions
pour moi c'est de soins td question
qu'on me pose est le regard des autres
change selon elle à qui je parle 21
heures au lieu dit quoi briser les
roches
et tantôt à leur tour de faire briser
j'ai envie de dire le jour où j'ai
assumé plein mal ce type de de
francophones et de franck ontarien qui
probablement autour de couchage et à
l'université voilà comme messi l'iodé a
dit sicilia la conjointe d'hier
probablement autour de ça que lieu
commun ni close
au lieu de parler de traumatisme s'il ya
eu comme une libération
comme une éclosion dans quelle mesure
les récentes coupes dans les services en
français du gouvernement fouad en
ontario pourrait vous inspirer à créer
une oeuvre par écoute les huiles s'est
pas encore remis l'état veille de se
faire taper saiful parler poète mais
poète on est tous mobilisés ailleurs
c'est un recueil qui s'en vient
dirigé par andry la selle une poétesse
de deux d'ottawa puis on et andré
dussolier ces pôles mais l'état avec de
recevoir 3 4 rim said mrs word ça ça
revient très rapidement
certains vous ont qualifié de michel
tremblay de l'ontario comment on prend
ce qu'on va dire ça avec une pression
c'est quoi il passe pour on merci merci
merci les prix les zones à tous on dit
merci on est très contents les très
content qu'ils aient déjà qu'ils
trouvent que ce qu'on fait vaut la peine
tout ça le reste on oublie qu à besson
passe à d'autres choses parce que c'est
vous
je me suis dit ça m'a pris au moins un
an un lit commence à écrire après le
premier prix du homard général c'est un
classique
les premiers prix littéraires les
premières honneur tout ça des tirelires
les auteurs on perd les pédales on
dirait qu'on est mal à personne oublie
aussi il faut qu on ne dépensait plage
une fois le kof est évident et on a dit
il est une autre
je pense que oui jean marc dalpé merci
beaucoup
les et quel plaisir